these engineering students from Adelaide
Australia make it onto our countdown
with this the world's longest bicycle
finally a bike big enough to get you
across Australia but how did these
Aussies create the Beast of all bikes
this bike is a hundred and thirty six
feet long that's forty one point four
meters and it seats 20 riders the frame
of this bike is made of steel and it
weighs three tons and it's able to
withstand the additional one and a half
tonnes of the riders the team has used a
truss design which means there's a bunch
of steel tubes a zigzag throughout the
frame that truss structure distributes
the forces more evenly relieving the
material and keeping it from bending so
this tighten of transport is strong
enough but is it actually rideable
building this bike was one challenged
but riding it was yet another was
designed for 20 riders and they did get
it moving with 20 but with each
additional rider the centre of mass of
the bike gets ever higher and with all
those riders moving back and forth kind
of randomly it's easy for the bike to
tip over because when the center of mass
isn't right over the center line of the
bike over you go on their second attempt
they reduce the amount of riders to just
seven and that lowered the center of
mass and they positioned most of those
riders towards the rear wheel which was
wider by changing their plan in this way
they were able to make the hundred meter
distance and secure the record
[Applause]